for
[Music]
this supposed to drive keep
organization
yes
stop let's
go go you're not
good put your weight on your knees
who maybe if you practiced 100% at the
time all right
watch when I get
on no just
feel is it getting tighter yes and say
yeah it's not going like this he
it gets
tighter you see right then this is Mercy
you see it gets tighter is like
go then is you feel the
way he you
see
wait say the ch
you
see on you feel it Mercy
look
how light I am
got to
gather come on go around it
[Music]
on push
P
see here hi mus hi that's where you're
getting pushed
hi I move
there but you can't push me right you
see right War
zero pressure if you count
[Music]
what for
too
low put your weight over your knees not
on your feet right since your feet off
the mat completely no
right wait on your
[Music]
knees W you want to keep your butt on
your feet
don't that would be weight over your
feet go Taylor
you mush right you you can't mush just
cuz you get
afraid you keep the form it's the same
training release the
fear
except not contesting isn't just pushing
at it it's retreating do you get it
that's
contesting it's not acceptance right
right we're not going fast that's that's
the point I was trying to make do I
really look like I'm trying I'm not
freaking trying
okay so it's all in your mind
right let's go
w
back leg on first stop the gry roll back
leg on
first back leg brings the arm
for don't fall on them
w
so right right here is the chance to uh
uh it's there's no
pain that that your response to the pain
is is already a
contesting just just just
accept he's moving like in slow
motion okay except there's going to be
weight on you
it's fine no one here is IR responsible
it's going to break your arm it's going
to be tight except accept the weight let
go do you understand you you're way too
tired do you feel how tired you are and
you're breathing hard and we're not
going nowhere
okay there should not be any fatigue was
was
you're spiritually you're in the same
boat Margaret was is that she was just
vocal about it but you're having the
same I can't
just let someone knee on
me right do you get it I want you to see
how fast he's he's actually moving make
sure you watch the
video
for for
sh
start
turtling you see
that guess how we got
here you're
turtling you feel like you have to
Turtle no now you see he's turtling
you're turtling
why what irr response you're
trying here if you tense
up get tighter right if you
relax
nothing nothing you
Turtle you're
countering you're seeking control he
goes He
Turtles we'll go
here he goes to
project you see this is control
again this
accept except
release under the
pressure try again all right thank you
very much it's not two Arts it's not two
practices all
right for
[Music]
now same thing you stay released he's
going to push that's his job don't fight
it okay don't try to control it by going
hyper Yin yield right that's not going
to work right accept and release inside
you go
good and weird you're up higher now
you're not sitting on your your butt on
your feet
[Music]
good natural
movement great
all right
so make sure you watch the
video in the matter
of seconds there's two
chrises you had two different
experiences
it affected not only how you received it
but how you were able to execute
it too
often because of the history that got us
here we
want some
Grand
Epiphany some fan
before we believe and
accept that this given time
space is not the only
one it is a
construct and I can change it
instantaneously we want
a huge Awakening experience
and you want to hear
voic and we want the
worldly recognition of such and
[Music]
titles but it it's not that's not
it I think that's a demonic
trick so you skip over
the actual hand of God reaching out to
you and I think it
is the way God is to
make that hand look less than it
is I think it I think it does
that it knows
your possessed self wants rings on it
wants it to be
bigger but your
spirituality has to
be in the everyday beingness of
life and we might dismiss what we just
saw what you just
felt but this
is nothing short of changing reality
you you want to pull a rabbit out of the
Hat it's easier to do that than to take
a human being and go
now you're in a different
world in the same way it's easier
to heal a blind person than to make the
world different for
them you have doctors can do
that it's easier to bring someone back
from the dead and to change someone's
world we have drugs we have
techniques all the Naran and all the CPR
and all the aeds will never change that
person's
Ro these things get
overlooked but these are bigger
Miracles you change someone's world
like that try
it and see if it's
possible you know it's possible but is
it possible for you is it possible for
them you can't
keep dismissing these things you have to
understand them for what they truly are
and when I have to say there's not two
Arts it's because you have your
techniques and then you have your maybe
your zazen you see or you have
your C iy cultivation
drills and then you have your techniques
you see
or you have your teachers
instructions the pointers that tell you
what to do and what not to do but you're
like no I only listen to the techniques
where do you step where do you put your
hand this is how we
get these mad discrepancies
so I say this to
you
first
prioritize and make
sure that you get
these so-called mundane simple things
how do I just move
naturally how do I not freak out as
you just take it
seriously don't move on to anything
else don't don't move on even to
surrendering to the teacher there's no
way do you do you understand that
there's no way you don't have it
in
you stay with this very simple
pointer release accept release
accept right don't don't go
entertaining what you now think is the
big stuff because you're
overlooking the little stuff and there's
no there's no surrendering to the
teacher and thus there's no surrendering
to
God if I can't just accept some
pressure do you get it it can't
accept I mean what probably is that 50
50 lb tops 80 lb that's it and you
cave and you want to wrestle
God come on man right do you understand
do you understand how how up
goofy that is
those are the old Tales When you you
they'd have some protagonist right
that's talking like
that and then the Lord of Dragons shows
up or the
Zeus shows up right goes
yeah let's
go okay and that person learns their
lesson you're not even close to this
stop talking like this stop orienting
like this stop thinking like this why
don't you just start with the simple
stuff can you take 50 to 80 lounds of
pressure without going into a panic
because if you
can't there's no
way do do you understand think about it
think about it
marget 50 80 lounds of pressure I I'm
going to go into a panic but I am here
trying to seek the communion with the
Divine which requires the deconstruction
of self which feels like the destruction
of
self you think the self is is is
destroyed with just 50 lbs of
pressure
no there's an inability to
breathe which you do not
have but because you're
yeling we can hear you breath that's not
what
happens when God's talents Pierce you
and push you down onto the earth that is
not what happens you cannot
breathe so we will task ourselves with
these very simple things
it's slow speed it's
low don't contest don't control
accept
release accept release no one's going
fast no one's going hard go it and you
actually do have
control where is it though
you see you still I still gave you the
throttle
right but no one hears an
if you watch he he didn't even
want to get on you
right right
right when you watching he's going slow
motion okay it's in it's in our minds
experiencing
this try it again